LOL the devil are you today is
spider-man on ps4s release day so I
thought we should play through a chunk
together if you want we can do the
entire game just let me know in the
comments but if you prefer this as a
one-off video that's fine too I can get
back to those list videos anyway
spider-man ps4 let's freakin do this
difficulty friendly amazing or
spectacular let's just not make it too
difficult let's just go
amazing we don't need any of these
options mmm let's just get on with
things how the music is epic I love the
music already
[Music]
mary-jane mr. Osbourne honors please
scanner we've all got one the feast
kitchen
lovely lovely plant
some sketches for spider gadgets
[Music]
I know there I was born look at all that
money he's got he can go on a vacation
anywhere
[Music]
scorpion Fisk Rhino vulture oh my word
it's going to be epic
Oh divide the controller vibrates the
controller vibrates with the phone
all units level for mobilization
locations visit our desk Fisk it's not
the big Willie
I can hit up I can do that every morning
[Music]
does that mean he has more than one suit
[Applause]
[Music]
is it soon Krisha hogan in the
background looking forward to that
but slightly having a big taped
[Applause]
police scanner election priority
spider-man priorities
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the war I'm in control now I'm in
control tattoos is swinging
a harvest field ethic we can jump at the
top of the swing
close to the ground Henry gets about two
come on please chop off did you take him
down yet no we're out there tower but
still waiting on the water
mind if I join in on the fun you know
how his lawyers are it's one needs to go
by [ __ ] come on Yuri I've been waiting
eight years for this you really want to
help head to ty somewhere sounds like
you guys are trying to keep my backup
for reaching the scene you got it almost
there
we're coming Yuri I can't put into words
how how this feels so damn good and the
web zip you can do by pressing X at the
peak of you jump that's pretty cool too
call me Peter Parker hello Parker where
are you
we must run through the demonstration at
least once before the grand committee
arrives yes sorry yes dealing with a
personal issue I'll be in soon
promise better wrap this up quick and
get to my real job quite like that well
wait the way MB the phone comes in so
his phone is always on the go
showing you how busy is showing his
duality of being spider-man and just a
normal bloke
[Music]
it's like you're recalled in the cab
look at the reflections and the clouds
I am muda man all the duties here
10:32 Times Square muffins is under fire
bring in the hammer
come on MC Hammer
what's the hammer
it's a big freaking tanker of course it
is that's gonna explode no black to
extract Hey
don't kill the police
here we go let's see what the action is
like Fran golf ball strike and that's
level a so when I spider sense tingling
that we press circle to dodge is awesome
we hold square uppercuts I can see
myself doing that a lot
this doesn't look good more enemies
somebody just shoot him I won repeatedly
don't think he meant like that try again
we'll try again touch bit late
[Music]
yeah hold square we know this
I looked at uppercuts almost done you be
there soon Willie's face you slap the
cuffs on ya the combi feels really nice
it feels like the ps2 version of
spider-man crossed with Arkham oh that's
how you finish it with a Superman punch
or a spider-man okay Yuri all done
what's happening Yuri Yuri
I'm coming Yuri
my new fist wouldn't go quietly I'm
still in or I promise I'll get over this
soon
it just feels so good
Stephen cut my feet off with a
helicopter
mr. Dawa
so many bullets but nobody dies in these
stories get more backups and lock down
the airspace Yuri you okay
you mix out that building we're gonna
lose him I'm gonna go do your thing go
things brother
Vica we know any window
let's pick the window that's close
build focus by attacking enemies
increase the combo sorry to break it to
you but you do not got this buddy Oh
dodging does make you feel like a
superhero it really does oh the loud
thud noise is when you've knocked one
out so you don't have to worry about
them anymore we're learning we're
learning slowly but surely focus bar
full how does that mean
we'll never find out
Oh random shot oh it's the teachers how
to heal press down on the d-pad okay we
get it we get it
let's move on I'll do it ask you to
perform either side of the zip team at
the edge
with your backup son who's your backup
[Music]
uppercutted off the edge that's how you
finish a bad guy they shut the elevators
down take the stairs I prefer a more
direct approach
I guess we're crawling up a wall
let's just open up a wall hoping that's
how we do things here our choppers are
taking fire
looks like Fisk has armed men on every
floor he's desperate
and he's hitting us with everything he's
got I have to find him and this not yet
we just picked up chatter they're wiping
all their data servers we need that
evidence if we want to put him away for
good
okay server room it is server room we
need to discover what pong they've been
viewing what's I don't think it is that
good
so zipline up oh yeah nice goodies just
funny bye bye darling
I shoved his friend that looked so cool
I'm making noises it means I like it I
like it a lot
I'm hiding in the bushes Oh press
triangle and circle narrowed enemy ninja
stand for me all right won't let the
finishing move like now on to the next
one
Lucha Libre I am Buddha man you want
some of this
your friend want some get him knocked up
the edge uppercuts for everyone
uppercuts you wanna depakote you are
uppercuts him I'm buildin hey you
you want another good gotta find that
server room before there's no evidence
left
if I go in this way they'll destroy all
the evidence
I should look for a sneaky way there we
go yeah it's like my own private
Ventress Ventress
hey where's the puddin counter maybe a
dirty criminal but he has remarkably
clean air vents hurry up bog wants
everything a rest square for a vent
takedown oh you're so cute when they're
living is he just going to die there and
live there the remainder of the small
less is this tech-support 47 seconds to
get this term we have to test out if
anything changes if we do lose the
mission 63 seconds we press it I'll show
you wait until the end
let's wait should we press it what
happens we fail the mission okay that's
enough miss myth-busting for one day
let's just do it correctly mix them get
an banza access that console before
everything's gone
let's see just how good their security
is oh you guys forgot the latest kernel
patch says the guy frantically erasing
his search history true but that's part
of my charm isn't it hold square to
perform under air launch oh we know this
a whole triangle to yung them bound
we've been doing that well there was
that time I took down a pompous
overstuffed crime lord before breakfast
I need to stop with the uppercuts don't
they
jury an explosion just I thought this
could have the whole place wired I'm
sitting in a bomb unit I'll make sure no
one gets in their way
you wanna see my uppercut
I'm gonna see my uppercut like a
firework shorter you figure out we're
not think that's all
where are we going next
nice office good office space it needs
some more natural lighting it's clear
move up hey guys I guess bombs are part
of Willie's get away plan
you go after them we'll look for the
bombs
buddy everyone clear out evacuate the
building I'll find them Buddha man you
need help
oh here we go this must be some bison
goodness oh wait we need more we need to
show how strong we are
[Music]
you all good look okay Willie coming
your way
spider-man it's Yuri
how we doing captain could be better our
choppers took a beating we just had to
ground our last one if Fitz calls on the
chopper we have no one to stop it from
landing and no one to chase him if he
flies away why do I get the feeling
that's what he was planning all along
because he probably was we're trying
whoa bazooka that looka get over there
that's a nice weapon you've got that's
enough out of you of course more of them
more buckets
before you can jump off yet mr. Ian
anomie
yeah
rocket launcher club there's a gift
we're knock you off the edge now get
gone can do it there he goes
see you mate so satisfying the bomb
squad guys get thrown or mark or mark or
get him get me the Jets down dogs knock
on wall impress Square to perform
off-the-wall attacks loving the little
wrestling moves to get here near 802 in
one house my Ida Mendez things around
here why am i doing my Batman voice I am
spider-man
you guys alright we were just about to
call for backup
take on it lead the way we'll be right
behind you
heads up boss boss please don't make a
social commentary about corrupt
robbers fight instead right different
enemies so we need to get behind them to
kick their butts
literally stop trying to shoot me bro
stop trying to hit me and hit me what
say you wanted okay good saying want
another uppercut
what's that chicken
you are gonna love flavors just for the
fighting your guys were on Fisk payroll
good news is they were Willy's last line
of defense
I'm right outside his office where to
spite him on doing spare time he stares
at the growth pleasure samurai statues
we've all been there open open says me
open thank you
Oh button
William we find you at last in your
samurai deck or home signing checks that
ass can't cash writing your memoirs
don't forget the hyphen between spider
and man Buddha and man get the chopper
ready I won't be long
who is our first boss fight I'm
surprised you made it this far but your
foolishness ends now I have a glass
screen you do know I can still see you
right ah for me you shouldn't have
I've seen this already is a case of
spotting those and then throwing them at
the window
easy baby how is this happening
What's Wrong Willie you seem angry I
will destroy you
[Music]
straight back out your bro jump over
smack you in the face
go hit him more keep smacking him it
straps come on in Big Willie let's do
this baby strapped into nothing yeah
webbing up oh no we can't throw it there
jump over then smack him in the face
Oh his heart I don't have enough left
dodge for a while there we go now you
can jump in and smack him in the big
balls for days
[Music]
I'm fine okay you are everything that's
wrong with this city huh oh it's gonna
say the same thing my suits getting
ridden or what to do so now is take out
the minions and try to dodge
I can handle myself
torture rack oh oh we got to time them
you got to time now so the QTEs what we
do el tuna oh just grunted at the wrong
time
in your face Willie
come on let's pound that Willy I believe
it is silver
the fight is over William you are mine
should we kiss now yeah maybe later we
did it we did it that was the opening 20
minutes can you believe it that's just
20 minutes Wow what do you got to say
for yourself finally off to Rikers huh
you know I think you've got more enemies
in there than I do
if you think this will be more than a
minor inconvenience gotta go hey good
luck Willie I have a feeling you're
gonna need it famous less words the
kingpin is heading to prison end of an
era you think I should celebrate maybe
take a vacation I need a vacation we're
gonna level up this is to see the RPG
elements let's see what we do we got
increased health skill points we have
six to spend hmm where to spend them in
fact I'll probably cut out all the
upgrades from this video you don't want
to see me trying to figure out which is
the best thing to use so I'll jump
around I'll actually I'll miss out
anything which isn't core story things
like learning to find the collectibles
or the random occurrence in the world
I'll skip those out of complete doubt
I'll skip those out completely and we'll
just do the story missions okay so now
with a random click of my finger we'll
go to the next story mission we need to
get to our job our day-to-day work I
think we're a scientist in this one
aren't we because we don't work for the
Daily Bugle anymore we don't take
photographs we have a real lab job sorry
I'm late let's see our bus
Oh reveal we work with dr. Octavius so
damn cool so damn cool he's going to be
the envis of the entire game I must be
the grant committee's director will be
here soon it's fine Parker I invented
this equipment I think I could handle it
look so cool shut the power first
maybe we should abort not yet hold on
doctor I think this okay another setback
but what close is anyone hurt no it was
always energy levels exceeded our
expectations from a certain viewpoint
that's a very positive development it
doesn't smell very positive
I assure you in the next phase let's not
get ahead of ourselves is there
somewhere else we can discuss this
whoever smelt it dealt it loaf maybe you
should take the rest of day off Peter
but we'll talk later coz that we late to
work and we get the rest of the day off
and we get to put out a fire now that's
the kind of career path I want that was
a disaster
oh I bet this place damn pure failed I
bet it's full of Easter eggs to take the
day off but I have to figure out what
went wrong let's find an Easter egg
there's a light here yeah remember that
time that Peter Parker had a banana and
a wrench okay maybe it's not full of
Easter eggs but you have to look harder
I think we've got samples of every type
of prosthetic in existence our first
volunteer subject Lance Corporal texador
wants to quit his doctor lost his arm
overseas and now just wants to hug his
daughter yeah remember that those were
the days Peter those were the days
don't think dr. Octavius is optimism has
ever been shaken what the heck is this
thing
it's amazing how could I know what it is
for evolved I know what it's for
Universal that's what it's for
yes I'm a big child
let's see what's wrong with you
Octavius industries welcome enjoy your
stay
also these must be the minigames circuit
burned out damn it if I'd been here to
do the pre check I would have caught
this oh they're locked so we have to
take the power all the way around so we
need one two three four five six seven
different ones component revert you are
a master technician you need to reroute
servo control
yeah I think Adam fast-forward through
all of that cuz I was damn boring to
watch I bet let's see if we fix the arm
now let's see if that worked let's test
out the masturbated machine it still
grabs junk oh I can dab it can dab hey
hey you man have 5 dab dab dab I need to
get a life
I really did Doc's been testing new
materials for the prosthetics they asked
me to review his work if I had time me
as well dig in now
duck was testing a new contact material
for the prosthetic ok this minigame is
about matching the patterns it should be
very simple hydrogel polymer composite
hydrogel polymer Hong because there's a
lot of impedance yeah that's what I was
going to set doc to keep looking for
other materials exactly what I was going
to say feet to park or my other job all
right I should get out of here before I
screw things up for doc even more yeah
agreed that was a good day at work
definitely earned my pay
just for those just in case I don't put
them in I've just done a few missions
about collecting bags and finding out
the radar towers work they aren't part
of the story so I've put them out so now
we're going back to where we work and
we're going to fix our spider suit
simple as that he walks like a badass
looks like Doc's gone for the night time
to sneak in some spider work spider work
spider what I need to stop singing one
video without singing sit it's all I
need Oh Barker dr. Octavius
what you got there Chinese if I know
you'd be here I would have what are you
working on oh just a side project a
secret it's out he knows of course it's
you oh yeah I I don't know come on
Parker it's obvious let me explain
I only wish you'd told me sooner I
wanted to but I was afraid that if word
got out my family might be in danger huh
yes I guess if you design his equipment
you're bound to be a target - yeah
designees equipment that's the one boss
yeah don't worry your secret's safe so
is yours
Doctor Octopus well I'll leave you to it
[Music]
what a nice man what a very nice man
[Music]
Marco Polo oh no check your email Auto
check your email
I hope this isn't how dock fires me
let's check Peter Peter the revelation
of your second job as spider-man suit
crafter is that the right term that the
right term is it a reminder is a
reminder of Union and partner you are
practice my American no matter how hard
you work you still find time to help
others I hope you don't mind but I
noticed the soup was a bit damaged and I
took the liberty of sketching up some of
my own improvements attached to a few
ideas I had on how you could enhance his
suit and help protect spider-man who
does so much for this city looking
forward to enough edible work that you
are doing and changing the world to get
together your partner and friend Otto
but a white spider huh hmm white spider
he just designed a suit for us whilst we
were asleep what a guy what a guy yeah
we'll use that bad boy yes we want the
advance to or we have to craft it hold
to craft look at that new suit he's got
a tiny package but that doesn't matter
he's nice and warm now
new sneakers bro
[Music]
hey miles see miles
[Music]
what's better yeah that does look damn
good it's weird isn't it how the first
suit looks so look so dated now just a
little bit of contrast bit of white on
you suit same old me I love this suit I
love this suit hey babes
check out my suit ladies and gents I'm
damn sexy so there's a there's a party
for Aunt May so we've gone to the feast
kitchen mr. Lee's probably in the
kitchen getting ready for the party the
only thing that probably cuts out here
are more side quests we're trying to
keep to the core story and that's it who
the heck are these ugly locks these must
be the people who made the game nice oh
this is spacious lovely place to live
hey man hey what's up just dropping in
he used to hook up it's not how you know
me hey Martin Martin Martin hey Martin
so sorry I'm late
you're right on time just keep her
distracted while we get everything ready
you got it
hey is my favorite aunt either need some
help
ah yeah sure oh there are some heavy
knots no no I mean I mean I mean not yet
I mean I came to uh I just just wanted
to talk okay okay um Peter are you in
trouble do you need my own no I mean I'm
a little behind on my rent but no no no
no I'm I'm fine
girl problems again huh oh that's great
I still wish you and MJ could work
things out she's a great girl she is but
the two of you would make some beautiful
baby uh Peter
what is it come on you can tell me these
past few years you helping me through
college and working here sacrificing so
much and asking for nothing I just wish
there were more people like you in the
world he's right
five years ago you walked in here and
told me you were inspired by my mission
to help others now it's you who inspires
me Thank You me for everything
mr. many more years of service
billion-pound may Olivia in the plastic
cake
thanks again for setting all this up no
I just wish I could do more
well maze always told me if you help
someone you help everyone maybe we
should send May to City Hall to have a
word with mayor ooh my controller is
vibrating oh I got a run thanks again
for the party and everything it really
means a lot
this is pretty good I like that the way
we can go between being spider-man and
we can go between being Peter Parker and
seeing his real life voice mail from
Yuri should check it outside check it
outside cash me out fat catch me hi Pete
you're answering the back I think thank
you thanks hey dude hey dude hey guys
how's the game going
it's gone I'm waiting get this guy
checked with dementia and crushing it
well the important thing is having fun
yeah yeah this is really interesting but
I'm gonna walk away and hope you don't
notice yeah
back on the streets what do you need
Yuri voicemail from Yuri Hey
silent alarm at the auction house
holding state sale just tripped could
you check it out quietly I don't want to
make a scene if it's nothing you know
keep Fisk estate sale sounds fun
wonder what the kingpin had hidden in
his closets better find a back way and
we'll take the roof Oh someone's about
to get killed
I am losing patience where is the file
there's someone else here they must have
taken it dose masks who are these guys
there's no one here but us we will find
the file or you will die this is bad
he'll kill her if I alert them all I
need to pick him off silent oh
stealth.stealth be too popular the
silent alarm is legit masked gunman in a
single hostage looks like a heist in
progress copy that
sending units your way keep the
situation from getting worse in the
meantime can do
got to do this quietly shoot webs
surfaces and objects to lure enemies
Jade I know who's there and then string
that mofo up they always look so cozy
wrapped up like that
just open the door man I cannot see a
thing maybe have to up the brightness
should wear them from above choo choo
choo choo if you just stay there and die
because no one can rescue you they will
have no idea to check the plumbing air
vents Wow
careful missions you stay quietly you
stay quiet bro you deserve before
someone's coming just see me down here
let's get up high
we're here I swear if they're here where
are they
so we can't string one up because you
either will notice so what do we do
instead can we wait from through
separate our we'll need to lure enemies
by webbing nearby surfaces it even says
it on the screen Adam you idiot
you imbecile okay we'll use it so we'll
string him up we should be able to just
jump at the second one now with a web
strike Oh sleep now
Prince hey what is that that's my camera
from The Daily Bugle
it's totally belongs don't move
ooh buddy if I had a nickel for every
don't move
hey Mary Jane hey Pete
MJ what are you doing here same as you
working at least it was oh I think this
is yours
yeah thanks so Robbie's got you covering
a break-in for the bugle well Robbie
doesn't technically know him here and it
wasn't a break-in until a few minutes
ago uh-huh
let me explain 15 minutes earlier
excuse me hi Mary Jane Watson I am
covering the Fiske estate sale hello
Craig said we do this tomorrow
I like to get a jump on things well I
don't you'll have to come back tomorrow
right okay I'm sorry hey Craig no sorry
it just it looks like we're gonna have
to run something else on the cover I
don't know maybe the expressionist piece
you know what I think I can make today
work right sure
you're here no moment like the present
Thank You Craig never mind we're good
let's get started
look around and familiarize yourself
with the items I'll be waiting by the
baku statue when you're ready to begin
can do okay let's start this interview
starting what do we do now a
one-of-a-kind game on Baku
oh come on Baku it's a Mifune Komunyakaa
boomboxes mr. Fiske has exceptional
taste he does do you know him well
before his arrest in a professional
context I handled many of his sales
let's move on please I need the jello
this is more important oh my gosh work
it jello mmm how much is it I'll buy it
now work it jello yeah work it okay I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming
what are we doing love oh you're
beautiful you bit oh oh yes yes the
front cover keep working and dying look
at those ankles gorgeous I'm not looking
at anything else there he loved the
duality I really should be paying
attention so just clicking like this
come on oh she loves it she loves the
camera the camera loves you too look at
those wristbands just everything is
about you is perfect my darling oh yeah
any touch to take a photo of this don't
ever anything irregular in any of the
sales you handle to him no no of course
not
not that I was aware of I don't think
your readers would have any interest in
phone call please don't be great you go
Craig Craig wait I recognize that statue
looks like a phone shut the statue what
Craig I'll call you back my dear I think
it's time for you to go oh um could I
use the restroom real quick fine
follow me thank you think we being
kicked out this is a really lovely space
it is and this will be the last time you
see it the ladies is around the corner
be quick guys our loot be right back I
really need to be you're gonna run I'm
gonna be my pants
if I pee my pants then you're in trouble
dumb jokes hello Craig funny you should
call because the reporter you sent is
clearly not working the puff piece we
agreed upon Oh No she's here - death
genius this is how you stealth got to
get into that [ __ ] over no one knows
where I am stealth people get suspicious
I get it we have to get over there let's
see if she notices us you never saw a
thing first thing I'm going to do is
have miss investigative journalists
arrested damn she's looking this way no
one earth can we do one thing I'm going
to do is collect your head Craig Craig
she's pissed right
run away was bumping down stealth Queen
underground
you know just do it go go go go go
notice she was looking straight at us
she's ridiculous uh-huh mm-hmm
oh no you didn't we yes I did here we go
the statue he told me about this this
kuester to hide evidence hide evidence
so we need to open it to take it I know
this statue opens how how do we open the
statue we look around there any clues
and he neeo behind them but it looks
different
is that oops okay that doesn't like so
it looks like it's poseable
what's these
okay this examining doesn't work he's
holding something so we need to put the
spiky thing in his hand okay easy enough
and any other info statue can move most
common pose is latent power mouth closed
left arm down right palm facing forward
hmm oh he can be posed different ways
okay okay so if we go over there and we
just change his position mouth closed
left arm down maybe I should turn right
now facing forward Souter it does I'm
facing forward we need the spear thing
and we need to put it in his hand and
that should be the end of it what do we
get vamonos born Devil's breath Devil's
breath if you read the comics you know
all about Devils that does all the holes
but Yakuza
excuse me sir you you can't be yeah like
you'd say that when you come in with
weapons and their faces are covered
excuse me in there we got defiled I'm
going to give it to Peter then it'll be
a Peter file
uh Peter file I was on my way to the
exit when I saw you you're lucky to be
alive this is the guy I saved five
minutes ago listen whoever these mask
guys are there after this file but I'll
never get it out of here well the place
is swarming with them right okay um you
hide back there I take out the bad guys
you make a break when it's clear sounds
like a plan
good to see you Pete good to see you
yeah you too
not exactly how I pictured us meeting
again now honey it's exactly how I
pictured it
[Music]
did she change her perfume
focus Pete focus she smells like burnt
toast
why are you showing me how to aim should
clear these guys out before I push
forward okay Pete let's take them down
good old web strike sweet restream sweet
prince okay I'll make a break for it
will do file what's in it that these
guys want so bad something called
Devil's breath Fisk was hired to build a
secret research lab for it not clear
what Devil's breath is but it seemed to
scare Fisk he compares it to Pandora's
box
not much shakes Fisk we need to get you
in that file out of here
hang tight how do we bring them in here
oh of course of course right we knock
onto that
where are you going just going to do
your own thing okay
tonight it's one down bring the other
one here I go no ok we'll shoot this one
gotta stay silent Hey
and we'll just leave you there no one
will notice you clear you're completely
obscured by everything else no one will
see you swinging around in broad
daylight
keep the stealth going let's keep it
going how do we break these keep it
tightly to the side oh no it's too loud
that's too long ok oops
yeah I think they know I'm here now
stop now I'm here
heis off okay
stays on the old bucket list there we go
we'll do this yeah this more look at
that axe that's a bit extra
[Music]
it's down how many left I have five
health we're gonna do this we got this
five health I like that
it'll do who's under the mask Jim Carrey
huh looks antique I think I know someone
who could help track down where this
came from Martin Lee a job for later I
just talked to Craig you are not the
reporter he was sending you don't even
work for heritage arts never said I did
hi Mary Jane Watson Daily Bugle yes you
will not write a word of what you saw
the record what do you know about the
file those masked men stole I do what
about the long history of stolen goods
Fisk has laundered at this auction house
your editor will be hearing from our
attorney Oh sexting hey Pete you okay
whoa he answers fast mix hey the last
six months never happened we're going on
a date
another date with Mary Jane sure see you
in a few oh wow okay we'll leave it
there we'll leave it there so that's
episode one shall we continue this shall
we play the entire game just the story
missions or shall we just leave this in
the past and I'll go back to doing what
I always do each week please say more
content like this this is the most fun
I've had in yonks doing this job anyway
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
hopefully I'll see you again tomorrow
you